[Musique]
alors j'étais ému parce que
y'avait christophe cazenove qui qui est
avec moi dans la salle c'est la première
fois qu'il assistait à la cérémonie des
césar et j'étais heureuse qu'ils soient
là donc j'étais ému de sa présence et
j'avais quitté mon bébé parce que jal
était à ce moment là donc ma
préoccupation et c'est qu'on ne voyait
pas le lait qui passait à travers ma ma
robe winner is
suivent les aînés avaient viré catherine
donné devant moi je me souviens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ce qui me remonte une urne avec kim
basinger
[Musique]
j'ai l'air d'un bébé
merci beaucoup le plus dur c'est pas ça
parce que ça s'est un peu c'est un grand
cadeau c'est un joli cadeau mais c'est
de continuer de continuer le chemin que
parfois pas facile il ya parfois des
grands bonheurs les grands donneurs se
les rencontres les rencontres de grands
metteurs en scène des gens qui ont
quelque chose à dire
comme christophe commanderie d'andré
téchiné jeux concours et beaucoup
d'autres encore qui viennent et a vécu
chez l'âge le plaisir est de travailler
je pense à l'est aussi par exemple qui
s'est arrêté et je souhaite une chose
est dite continue parce que c'est comme
ça que le cinéma vit là j'ai eu une
sorte de pincement de coeur parce que
parce que j'ai pensé à des oscars hague
avec qui j'ai fait un film difficile
mais ô combien beau les amants du pont
neuf
est ce qu'au cinéma en fait c'est rien
c'est juste une grande loupe qui
montrent la vie et si à travers le
cinéma qu'on peut atteindre les gens et
qu'on peut leur donner le lan vie et
l'espoir de continuer merci beaucoup
j'avais à la fois le coeur qui bat r et
et un prix c'est une énorme joie est à
la fois c'est une responsabilité qu'on
n'a pas toujours envie d'endosser parce
que on se sent enfin moi en tout cas
peut-être ses mains c'est mon éducation
mais il ya une sorte de quelque part de
culpabilité qui est pas lointaine
mais en tout cas ce soir là j'étais
j'étais tellement heureuse c'est d'abord
c'est un tournage heureux j'étais fier
du film
et j'avais un pis voilà j'étais heureuse
dans ma vie et d'ailleurs quand j'avais
vu catherine je me suis fait qu'elles
s'étaient retournés comme ça pour me
saluer et je n'avais pas été présente et
je vais regretter en fait parce que
c'est vrai qu'au sénat on est un peu
intimidé un peu voilà il ya des gens
qu'on connaît plus ou moins bien alors
on dit bonjour très facilement jeunes
gens qu'on connaît les autres on est en
tout cas moi je suis un peu intimidé je
le vois bien et
et catherine j'avais croisé plus que je
la connaissais ça faisait partie d'un
des petit regret de cette soirée là
alors il est dans le dos de mon
assistante parce que je ne veux pas même
si c'est pour moi c'est un clin d'oeil
parce que petit j'étais plutôt l'avant
dernière que la première mais pas ce que
je veux je veux être libre
voilà donc libre dans le sens où
bougez pas ce poêle gp j'ai le droit de
me tromper j'ai droit d'être mauvais
j'ai le droit de j'ai le droit de pas
avoir de prix pour venir ici on assiste
en inde il faut que tu apportons dont
césar pour l'émission julie et elle la
sortie elle a mis sur la table
voilà de la cuisine j attends j'ai pas
venir avec avec moi avec mon césar est
en fait je me suis rendu compte que
d'abord il avait vieilli qu'il était
tout noir et que je les mets en fait pas
forcément doré parce que le métal cette
histoire et ça ça change mais je trouve
que c'est un bel objet je trouve que il
est beau à regarder
c'est rare parce que souvent les prix
cdd bonhomme tout droit des bonnes
femmes sais pas comment la victoire
machin mais je trouve que la une un
équilibre et puissent compliquer sa
rentrée dedans et c'est vrai que d'avoir
un césar c'est une
c'est un vrai cadeau quoi ces épices et
la reconnaissance de ses pairs et ça
c'est pas rien parce que la longue la
route et est longue et solitaire en face
d'une caméra y'a une solitude on rentre
vraiment soi et même si on est très
accompagné qui a ce rapport si intime
est si fort avec un metteur en scène et
aussi avec le chef opérateur l'équipe en
face est un tout il y a quand même
l'idée quand même d'une entrée en soi et
donc la reconnaissance de ses pairs il
ya grâce à ces voix là c'est à ces
soirées à ses symboles finalement une
sorte de
de chaleur qui exprime et de voilà ça
c'est que c'est pas rien la chaleur
exprimé par l'autre elle elle va
vraiment droit au coeur
[Musique]